are the photos from the iphone 13 really
that much worse than the 13 pro and is
it really worth spending an extra 200
to get that telephoto lens and the macro
capabilities well today we will find out
in my detailed comparison we're going to
take a look at a wide variety of shots
in different lighting including night
mode the macro shots portraits i'll show
you every single difference and believe
it or not in some cases the iphone 13's
photos are actually better while in
other shots the 13 pro smokes the iphone
13 so let's go ahead and jump right in
starting out with this shot here with
standard shots and good lighting they
look almost identical the colors the
contrast the white balance they're all
tuned the same the detail to the eye
looks basically the same and if we crop
in you guys could tell that they look
the same same thing with the ultra wide
lens right here and mixed lighting and
the standard lens they look the same but
when we switch to the telephoto shot wow
guys look at that difference not only
can you zoom in 15 times on the 13 pro
instead of five times the difference in
detail is noticeable right away and if i
crop in so that the framing looks the
same i mean the 13 shot looks like a
joke we have all the artifacting there's
no detail whatsoever now of course a lot
of people don't zoom in that much so
here's a shot at 3x and in perfect
lighting we do see some differences in
detail but it's not a deal breaker but
if you zoom in any more than that like
this five times zoom shot you could tell
the difference in detail with the 13 pro
looking amazing the trees in the
background are detailed whereas the 13
not only do you lose so much detail you
have artifacting in the little numbers
for the airplane and in general and then
also with that in skies you all start
getting all this artifacting and noise
the shot just looks so much worse here's
a 10 time zoom shot when i saw a rabbit
in my yard i mean one side looks like a
cartoony waxy mess where the other side
actually looks like a photo that you can
keep in your phone now there's a few
more benefits of having that telephoto
lens apart from zooming the first one is
if you're taking a portrait shot so
let's compare portraits as you can see
the 13 pro has that nice compression
looking more like a professional
portrait shot now the 13 shot also looks
really good but of course the pro can
also take that sort of a portrait with
the standard lens but then when it comes
to taking shots like these where once
again we have the nice bokeh we have
that nice compression
you just can't reach it the shot on 13 i
also like but it doesn't look the same
now i know some people say hey you can
always just crop in to mimic that
compression and yeah you can look at the
shot right here where i cropped in but
look what happens one to the detail it
looks a lot less detailed but then look
at her face it's stretched out because
of that wide lens taking the portrait
shot now of course uh you can actually
get closer for example here i'm standing
in the same spot taking a portrait the
13 pros with that telephoto lens so i
can walk up closer but once again we
actually hit that distortion where
vadim's being warped he just doesn't
look like himself and then we also
notice the flaring in the shot which
we'll talk about in just a bit now
here's a more extreme example if you're
taking a headshot that telephoto lens
comes in very handy being able to take
this natural pleasing looking image
compared to just stretching out the
image if you take a photo like this with
a standard lens now with that said there
is one major advantage that i found with
the iphone 13 over the pro models and
that is taking an image of an object
that is large here you guys see the
side-by-side here that is beautiful and
with the 13 pro shot we do not have any
portraits there you see the background
is fully in focus where the iphone 13
was able to take that portrait shot
makes the image look great makes the
side by side stand out from the
background now i believe this has
something to do with the lidar sensor
here because i took a similar shot in my
last comparison with the iphone 12 pro
max as well and the 11 pro max the 12
pro x also couldn't do this while the 11
pro max which does not have a lidar
sensor just like the iphone 13 did take
a shot with that portrait blur so i
really like this capability now there is
a downside for example this shot right
here we're using the same lens same
distance and the 13 has the blur messing
up that sign that's because lidar is
useful for depth information you guys
can see the 13 pro has a nice clean
cutout at the top and then of course we
have the option to use the telephoto
lens which makes the shot look so much
better with that compression there in
the background the same thing goes when
you're taking a shot like this this is a
super difficult shot both phones did a
great job but having that compression
gives you extra separation and the
background isn't as you know present
there you're most mostly focusing on the
subject which is the airplane now here's
a tip for you guys as long as you're not
taking a portrait shot with the standard
photo mode you can actually zoom in a
little bit and mimic that compression
you're kind of getting rid of that wide
lens and here the photos look fairly
similar we don't see too much background
there we're focusing on the subject but
of course you could tell that the detail
level definitely goes down now of course
the other option is just to get closer
like we did before but then you guys see
all of that outside of the window that
really distracts from the photo next i
wanted to jump into macro shots and here
you guys could see i'm using the
telephoto lens and with the 13 pro it
looks nicer it is sharper now this
wasn't using the new macro mode that you
get with the 13 pro so let's switch to
that and right here you guys can see i
got insanely close to this slug right
here the detail looks good gives you a
perspective that you normally don't get
compared to the 13 using the standard
lens now of course i can actually use
the 3x telephoto lens as well if i cover
up that macro and that gives me a nice
pleasing image without any background in
the shot and it looks nice and sharp now
here's the closest that you can get
using the standard lens on the 13 and
the telephoto on the 13 pro but of
course with that macro mode we can get
crazy close you see the difference right
there we get the bokeh in the background
that still shows up and then with the 13
of course yes you can crop but it looks
like junk you have a lot of noise
artifacting no detail at all so the
iphone 13 definitely cannot compete with
that macro lens now another difference
that i noticed is dynamic range
surprisingly when you're really pushing
it you see that the 13 is blowing out
the highlights a little bit more and
then here in this shot that i zoomed in
of course we have more detail because
the telephoto lens look at the
background right there where it's bright
on the top right you see better dynamic
range with the 13 pro which i was not
expecting and here's a shot that just
blew me away now both of these phones
are supposed to have the same front
facing cameras they're 12 megapixel
sensors but here the 13 pro is exposing
for the background more so so i have a
little bit more noise on my shirts but
look at that image with the sunset
compared to completely blowing it out
with the 13 which looks more like an
iphone 12 or an 11 so i wonder if there
really are some differences in terms of
hardware now another thing i noticed
here same exact lens and i didn't do a
lot of selfies because i thought they'd
be identical but we're getting more
flaring on the 13 the sun was right
there behind me and less contrast which
is really weird now flaring in general
has gotten a lot better with the 13 pro
unfortunately the 13 has not had the
same treatment if we look at the photo
here we have um flaring in the sky it
stands out more so and we have less
contrast with the bridges with another
little round ring of flaring kind of
messing up that shot and now let's make
this even more interesting and go into
night mode shots starting out with right
after sunset here it's actually
interesting that the 13 shot looks
better
the 13 pro looks darker and in general
the tuning might be slightly different
between these the 13 looks more like an
iphone 12 photo which by the way like i
may have mentioned the cameras in this
phone are from the iphone 12 pro max
this right here is a 3x shot using the
telephoto lens on a tripod so it's 10
seconds exposure and of course we have a
lot better contrast less flaring you
guys notice that and in general it does
look quite a bit nicer now here's a shot
which was at night but it had a lot of
lighting on the street and you start to
see the differences between the new
upgraded lens that is in the 13 pro and
the one that came from the 12 pro max
into the iphone 13. we do have more
contrast we have a little bit better
colors a little bit more detail starting
to notice the difference more so and
then switching to the ultra wide here we
have an even bigger difference where the
13 pro looks sharper more detailed
better in pretty much every single way
now it does get interesting that when we
go inside um into this kind of medium to
darkish lighting the 13 actually looks
nicer here um one thing that i found
between these two is because the sensor
is larger and newer inside the 13 pro
apple is making it much quicker to take
night mode shots and this is something
that most people don't talk about with
the 13 this shot was about three seconds
compared to one second so you get more
convenience less chance to blur but in
some cases like this the 13 actually
looks better and then switching to the
ultra wide then you guys notice that the
13 pro
you do have more detail once again and
it overall looks darker and that's what
i'm talking about where um the 13 looks
more like the iphone 12 photos a little
bit brighter at night now as far as
portrait mode in lower light situations
they look pretty much identical and then
same thing here with the subject very
very close but when it comes to really
dark portrait shots you guys could tell
right here the 13 pro looks so much
better more lifelike and that is because
thanks to that lidar sensor you can
combine night mode shots and portrait
mode shots whereas the iphone 13 will do
only one or the other and you really see
the difference here look at his jeans
you get all that extra detail less noise
compared to the iphone 13 which is
crushed with more noise and then the
extreme scenario where in this case it
literally won't let you do portrait mode
because it's too dark on the 13 whereas
the 13 pro can actually do a portrait
mode shot and night mode it looks a lot
better now here's a shot i want to show
you guys the differences between the
lenses and the sensors this is actually
without night mode turned on and you see
the 13 pro it's a little bit darker but
it's a lot less noisy with less
artifacts in the sky and then we
actually flip when it comes in to
zooming because the 13 pro is using that
telephoto lens that lets in a lot less
light compared to the 13 which is just
cropping in on that image and because of
that in certain situations like this
where you have not too dark of lighting
the difference is very little even
though we're cropping in three times
with the iphone 13 and the same thing
goes with this night mode shot it's very
very close in terms of detail even with
digital crop on the 13 but if it gets a
little bit darker that telephoto lens
with the night mode kicks in and look
how much better this looks we're so much
more zoomed in with so much more detail
and color and then if i crop to match in
the framing i mean that is just it's
crazy the difference in quality that you
get switching to the standard lens right
here i know this shot looks like it's
fairly bright but my eyes literally
could not see anything this right here
is a 10 second exposure uh hope being
handheld with both of these images and
in fact 13 actually turned out better
for some reason even though both were 10
seconds so props to the 13 here and this
one is a 30 second on a tripod so i'm
not limiting it at all the 13 pro does
look like it's a little bit more
detailed a little bit sharper with that
faster lens but when you're stacking 30
seconds of images the difference is
fairly minimal but then when we switched
to the ultrawide you guys could see that
the new updated ultra light in the 13
pro allows you to take a much brighter
much more detailed nicer looking shot
even if it's 30 seconds of photos
combined on a tripod that's a best case
scenario for the iphone 13 and the 13
pro still comes out way ahead and the
same thing goes if you're hand holding
it right here you guys can see how much
brighter and better the 13 pro's
ultrawide looks when it's really dark
now i didn't do a lot of detail because
they are very similar in most ways
there's a lot less differences in terms
of video
but what you can see the difference is
when you are starting to zoom in this
right here is that 3x the 13 pro looks
much better the 13 is noisy with a
little bit of artifacts and then of
course you can zoom in much more and
even though we're so much closer here
the image still looks less noisy and
less artifacted than the 13. of course
both of these can shoot cinematic mode
which is awesome they have hdr video but
only the iphone 13 pro can shoot pro res
and then with that remember you have to
have a 256 gig model which is why i
ordered that one for the first time
if you want to shoot 4k with pro res so
there you guys go there are all the
differences between the camera so what
do you guys think does the 13 pro
warrant the extra 200 for its camera
capabilities compared to the 13. of
course you guys want to hear my opinion
so i think yes absolutely it absolutely
does even if you don't care about any of
the other differences between these
phones if you care about photos 200
is worth it you get a lot better
capabilities you guys saw the macro
shots you guys saw some of the night
mode shots of course we have those zoom
shots and those portrait shots my
goodness they look so much nicer having
that capability of course let me know
your thoughts and if you guys wonder
what other differences are there between
the 13 and the 13 pro well i did a one
week later review showing all the real
world differences if you guys want to
see that video check it out right over
there click that subscribe button above
if you guys want to help us reach our
goal of 1 million subscribers we would
really appreciate it this has been max
and i will see you in the next video
[Music]